we are back with former president Donald
Trump for the entire hour and here is
more of my interview from Mar-A-Lago the
economy
I can't even say strongly enough is in
complete channels we have 60 percent of
our country now living paycheck to
paycheck CBS News now says 25 of people
in our great country are what they call
Food insecure food that can't get Bare
Necessities recession record inflation
record our debt our deficits you know
why is this happen how would you fix it
and would you have supported the bailout
of Silicon Valley Bank okay ready yeah a
lot of questions you're asking me I am I
wouldn't have supported the bailout the
bank would have to get along by itself
and maybe they could have what happened
with the bank's interest rates went too
high and you know I had my own situation
with Powell and I beat the hell out of
him I was not a big fan of Powell I was
he was recommended by some people I
didn't like them he's too interest rate
happy what you do is you get the oil
prices down that's bigger than it's the
only thing and what happened is we took
an oil and now we take an interest rates
those banks failed because the interest
rates were too high they stupidly
brought long-term treasuries 10-year
treasuries well they bought long term
longer than that even and they would
long term and
those treasuries got crushed because
Powell keeps raising interest rates but
that's up to Biden he's going to have to
worry about that himself you know in
theory how would you fix it uh well I
would have done a big number on pal like
it did I did I did a very big number in
fact uh he wasn't budget he wouldn't
have given up eventually he eventually
cut him so much
that it almost caused the problem people
said how come he's cut him he helped cut
him almost a point immediately because
he thought I was going to fire him okay
which some people said I had the right
to do other people said you know you
know when you put them there rightfully
they have to have some protection etc
etc from a president but how much of
this but I thought he was hurting the
economy you left this country for the
first time in 75 years we were energy
independent right a net exporter of
energy okay we're going to be dominant
okay okay and Europe right now could
have used American Energy they could
this winner they could have used it so
but now Joe has cut back dramatically on
domestic production of energy now we're
important believable we're importing
from Venezuela Saudi Arabia last year
their their big oil company made the
most money they've ever made in history
over I think it was over 167 billion
dollars how much of that because doesn't
energy impact uh Trucking it impacts the
price of goods in every store that we go
to so when Biden came in the first thing
he did was end the Keystone Pipeline
that I got approved okay it was all
approved I also gave Putin a waiver on
the Nordstrom too okay so Putin said
because everyone said oh I'm so nice to
Putin Putin said if you're my friend I'd
hate to see you as an enemy he told me
that I got along very well with Putin by
the way I'd be able to work that out it
would have never happened in a million
years and even the Democrats admit that
but if this thing isn't solved by the
time we have the election which is
possible it won't be and there's also
possible we'll be in World War Three
where these idiots that are doing what
they're doing you could end up in a
nuclear World War which will make World
War one and World War II look like Patty
Cakes okay uh this unbelievable because
we have people that don't know what
they're doing but if it's not solved I
will have it solved in 24 hours with
zelinski and with Putin and there's a
very easy negotiation to take place but
I don't want to tell you what it is
because then I can't use that
negotiation it'll never work but there's
a very easy negotiation to take place I
will have it solved within one day
a peace between them now that's a year
and a half that's a long time I can't
imagine something not happening the
chairman the key with that is the war
has to stop now because Ukraine is being
obliterated you know whether there'll be
nothing left well I looked at pictures
of cities that are literally like it's
like complete that demolition I was in
the construction business you would
demolish a building and you'd it looked
like hundreds of these demolition sites
the built this wasn't a building
standing and these are cities for
Ukraine they were big cities very big
cities now he hasn't really in Kiev he
hasn't really set the missiles in but at
some point he'll do that one too
there's nothing standing the other thing
is many more people are dead
and horribly injured then they're
reporting you know when you see missiles
hitting 15 buildings at 15 buildings
falling to the ground and they're big
buildings there are a lot of people in
those buildings and then they say one
person was injured these are phony
reports many many people are being
killed that you don't know but you'll
see that later on so you'd prefer if you
were president you think you could you
would have a negotiated settlement and
within 24 hours and we wouldn't no
longer be ponying up all the money that
by the way western western Europe is not
doing their fair share what's unfair you
and I have had this conversation is that
we are spending we're up to almost 150
billion dollars
and Europe's at 24 billion dollars now
it was the same thing with NATO don't
forget I got them to put up hundreds of
billions of dollars my first meeting at
NATO you know I was just there never did
this before I'm sitting with all these
presidents and prime ministers nice guys
28 countries and I'm looking at the
charts I said could I see who's
delinquent because they're supposed to
pay and they say what do you mean by
delinquent they said that's a real
estate term when you don't pay your rent
you're delinquent could I please see uh
who has not paid and of the 28 countries
20 were not paid they weren't paying and
I said you have to pay and if you don't
pay I'm not going to protect you
and ahead of a very important country
stood up and said who is delinquent said
could I ask you if we don't what you're
saying if Russia attacks us
and we aren't paid up you're not going
to protect us I said that's exactly what
I mean hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else